hey everybody real quick before we dive
into this quickie episode of the
minimalist we want to help you declutter
all of your glowing screens so head on
over to the minimalists comm slash
wallpapers over there you're gonna find
a bunch of beautiful simple wallpapers
for your smartphone or for your computer
desktop you'll find the love people use
things wallpaper you'll find the less is
now wallpaper you'll find five questions
to ask yourself before buying wallpaper
you'll find my personal favorite the
minus sign the minimalism sign wallpaper
and you're gonna find several others in
the coming weeks we have scrolling is
the new smoking
coming soon you're gonna find the you
can't change the people around you but
you can change the people around you
wallpaper and several others over at the
minimalists comm slash wallpapers
download yours for free today and
declutter all the devices in your life
I'd like to see mayor Pete read some
onion headlines about mayor Pete are you
are you willing to do that sure we got
some good ones got four or five of them
for you here all right Pete footages
tons campaign crowd by speaking to
manufacturing robots in fluent binary as
a picture of it everything is so good so
this is like a play on yeah of course
like you know you learn Norwegian to to
read that book but so you don't know
binary that I do not yeah although yeah
not to be do binary about it right cuz
there's no language I've mastered I'm
getting there with English but but but
yeah I love languages and I've studied a
lot of they're all getting pretty rusty
because I don't have a lot of occasions
for busting out the Norwegian when I'm
campaigning although of course it's
helpful to speak Spanish if only to you
know even my kind of serviceable high
school Spanish just lets people who
speak Spanish know that that I care
about them and want to hear what they
have to say but no I love languages I'm
not sure binaries gonna make I probably
try to learn sign language before it's
probably good call list yeah well we got
next year
Pete village' to elicit releases
comprehensive list of fun personality
quirks to include in articles about him
the thing is like you are sort of the
fun personality quirk candidate and a
lot of our truly meaningful and I think
that's why it's easy to sort of to mock
it was like yeah he happens to be the
millennial
gay married Christian a war veteran who
spent yeah all of these things but yeah
I mean do you have that list handy no I
think I'm running out of quirks gotta
come up with some new ones name kind of
beats him out of you let's go ahead and
see that all right this next one is and
this is geared toward a mayor running
for president for sure 2020 presidential
candidate Pete footage announces bold
plan for 2,500 mile Intercontinental
Riverwalk okay I think it's a great idea
I biked across the country three
Millennials sitting here yo we all think
it's a great idea the priority I'm all
for it I mean this is I think the
mayoral mentality is going to do a lot
of good in the Oval Office
you